I don't know the ones in my books are
pretty bad I don't I don't necessarily
count myself a fan of the vampires that
appear in a lot of contemporary fiction
you know I just don't buy the the
vampire as hero construct at least not
when seen from the viewpoint of of a
human character they vent maybe hero's
in her own eyes but to us to them we are
we're a cattle and I can't I can't see
the 500 year old vampire falling for a
high school girl kind of scenario
[Applause]
my vampires were science-fictional
reconstruction of vampires and fever
dream they were not supernatural but
they rather were a predatory race that
exists had existed in an among humanity
while spraying and humanity since the
dawn of time disguising themselves as us
by a certain mimicry but nonetheless
preying on us and immensely long-lived
and powerful beasts essentially
predators evil by our standards not by
their own standards I mean as a as a
lion evil as a tiger evil not by the
standards of Hawaiian at a tiger but
they're certainly evil by the standards
of the goat or the wild beasts but I
also felt that as intelligent creatures
reasoning creatures vampires would be
capable of developing a moral sense and
of making choices under the right
circumstances and that is indeed the
moral question at the heart of fever
dream between that the character Joshua
Loras M representing one side of the
struggle and the the older vampire Damon
Julian representing the the other you
know the question is should you should
you accept your nature or should you
aspire to improve your nature by your
intelligence this is an issue that by
the way you you know one still sees
debated today in all sorts of contexts
be it political biological scientific
you know research scientific research
reveals certain things about the human
beings and there
there's no doubt in my mind the the
Christian loonies of my own country
notwithstanding that evolution is real
and we are evolved monkeys what does
that do must to be forever monkeys
despite the fact that we have these
aggressive and anti-social impulses and
things like that and and all of us have
this in us surely we can aspire to be
gods surely we can aspire to be angels
to overcome our nature and you can see
this in a lot of my work not just in not
just in fever dream the question of
making choices what what will you do
when you reach a certain crucial point
under conditions of of high stress as
for the political dimensions of the
question about vampires you know being
among us or worse than vampires yeah I
can sort of see where you're coming from
with that I don't pretend to understand
the crisis that you guys are going
through in in Spain or that all of
Europe is going you know Greece and
Portugal and Italy and indeed the entire
European Union I'm not an economist and
much of this is Greek to me so to speak
it certainly complicated issues but you
know I see this the struggles in my own
country the the collapse of the economy
which is was brought on largely by the
vampires you speak of by corporate greed
by people operating at high levels that
the political struggles to you know
balance the budget and increasingly
demand on the part of the wealthiest
portion to pay less and less in terms of
taxes and to shift more and more the
burden
the lower classes and two at the same
time eliminate more and more services
for the lower classes I mean you guys at
least have health care where we've just
got that in our country and we're
struggling to keep it so we have an
entire political party it is man
mounting a major presidential campaign
on a goal of eliminating health care and
millions and millions of Americans are
going to vote for this in yeah I can't
even hardly begin to explain it to you
why anyone would do that but nonetheless
it's it's going to happen and we're
facing a terrible a terrible struggle
there I look for my point of view of
someone who's read a lot of history and
and I see these struggles have been
going on all through human history you
know I go back to the ancient Greeks and
the Greek city-states Athens Sparta
Thebes Corinth each one of them having
struggles between the Oleg arcs on one
hand and the Democrats on the other hand
and it's it's always just to struggle
between the the rich and the powerful on
one hand and the rest of the population
on the other hand someone asked me in an
interview the other day about science
fiction and why science fiction is less
popular than it once was obviously and
fantasy has become much more popular and
I think it's because the at least of the
United States and possibly here and in
Europe as well a lot of people have lost
faith in the future which science
fiction represented and the great dream
of space travel of that we would go to
the moon and we would have bases on the
moon and we would go to Mars and
eventually humanity would spread out
among the stars and all of that no one
seems to really believe that anymore and
it doesn't seem to be the the real faith
that our children will have it better
than we have it and their children will
have it better than they have it instead
there's just a reversed as these worries
about global warming and
the worries about pollution of the
ecosphere
you know peak oil energy running out
where the where the renewable energy
resources to replace it how long can
this industrial civilization last if
energy does will run out answer by the
way
not long so where is this all gonna put
us I you know I don't know but it does
it does depress me when I think about it
I I think all we can do you know as a
writer I write my books and I
occasionally influence people with
statements on my blog perhaps but I
think ultimately it's up to the people
of each individual country and my
country in particular being the last
superpower in the world and exercising a
frighteningly disproportion
disproportionate amount of power over
the world to try to address some of
these problems and I think particularly
it falls on the younger people in this
audience I hope you guys are doing
something about it and my generation you
know when I was one of these proverbial
younger people I was out there trying to
get us out of Vietnam and you know a
part of movements the first Earth Day
the ecology movement all of these things
to try to produce a better world and we
had some victories and we had some of
the feats I think by and large we made
the world a better place than we left it
but that doesn't mean that utopia ensued
and utopia will never ensue it has to be
fought for again with each generation
and if it's not fought for if people
just let the vampires rule then I gotta
warn you winter is coming
[Applause]